no I'm just kind of discovering filters
now they make you look so tan so when I
first got instagram I thought it was
just a photo editing app I didn't
realize it was like a social network so
I was just like going onto like editing
pictures like for funsies here's my
first one paper clips and it might have
been my phone background for like a hot
minute I post pretty often and I say
that I've gone through several phases
with how I use Instagram is called the
art because it's a dart board or the
coca-cola Kanna this is when I started
incorporating branding so people know I
am open for sponsorship definitely did
it work no very first one is it was I
was drunk and I just wrote a caption
that says be afraid be very afraid and I
guess I was like trying to scare people
that I was on Instagram what is that an
umbrella are you sure it looks like a
one of those like Tiki umbrellas that
you drink
it wasn't the the cheapy plastic
umbrellas from the dollar store this was
like one of those table umbrellas at the
University of Miami and I was just
sitting there bored I guess and I was
like art time to take a photo all right
everywhere got two likes for those of
you that can't tell there's a milk in
the Brita pitcher one drunken night I
accidentally not accidentally I
obviously do this on purpose I have no
recollection but I poured milk into a
Brita pitcher Lisa I thought Instagram
at first was a filter app like
specifically just to filter things so my
friend was like hey you got a longboard
and I was like yeah I'm a cool kid in
college I got a longboard so I literally
took the photo thinking only it would
say I didn't know and you'd like my
first photos or here for the world to
see if you like the thirst is very real
for like first years of college stuff
like dry as the Sahara Desert I want to
find me a woman thirsty okay
another bad one of me with a basil plant
but I've only put in focus one of my
eyes it was a real fun way to use it but
now I mean it's really just my actual
life
hi hey guys here we made a series it's
coming on November 18 please watch it
give it here yeah yeah oh man you got it
do you see it it'll be released 2015
November okay